it was 50 years ago when you draw one
frame
you can eat on ramen but the rate of the
life
increase but the inflation yeah that's
the price
so now if you want to eat a ram and you
have at least
do a five or six frame oh my god am i
allowed to ask you what that might
be a frame uh well when you're in
betweener
you are paid like it
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste the anime podcast where we
talk about japan
uh food [ __ ] and occasionally anime
i was trying to remember what i said
last week
i think that's what i said last week i
am your host for today
again and joining me is as usual the
boys and
once again we have a guest as i'm
hosting
we have uh ken arto do you want to
introduce yourself and what you do
yes uh nice to meet you my name is ken
arto i am a cunymater in japan
since 2015 and so i'm
i had work on projects like dragon ball
super brewery
my hero academia jojo a lot of things
yes and
and i am actually animator at the studio
4c
oh okay wow well we have a quick spread
of
some of the shows you worked on not
everything wow you worked at masters
universe
yeah i like pretty much a shonen gem so
yeah
yeah i mean obviously this isn't all the
shows that ken's worked on but you know
these these are the
probably i'd say the most notable ones i
mean there's obviously more like uh you
know the recent juices of kaisen this is
guys
yeah episode 16 right 16 will be
this friday oh yeah and recently also uh
kim is a movie oh my god oh my god
you casually dropped that that's one
hell of a cv well thank you very much
for coming on because
it's nice to have someone who's actually
been working in the industry and is
knowledgeable about
what it's actually like working in there
instead of just having three guys we're
just sitting in the room
just just taking guesses taking pot
shots technology like you know
knowledgeable guests sometimes not
knowledgeable guests
yeah i think when we don't have a guest
it's like don't listen to what we say
yeah we don't know what we're talking
about but then we're literally like
first hand like source right yeah now
now we can get the answers at the same
time as our audience
right right i am curious if there was
you know perhaps one
scene or one show that you you would
recommend for someone to watch to maybe
experience your work the best what would
you
actually maybe say actually i'm working
in a
movie for studio fossee i can say the
name
uh actually yeah i on this movie i
put all my guts and so yes you have to
wait a bit but
episode 6 so i think it's a good shot i
have done so
yeah i mean how long have you been
working in the industry now uh
so we we could don't count my internship
it will be now five years
and so i start as in-betweener so the
right between frames right yeah
and i have done this for one and a half
and after i have switched off schedule i
went to yapik animation
the previous studio was a graphene and
uh yapiko pico i made so uh two year and
a
half
and after uh after your pico now i'm a
studio four c
c wow because like it's it's because
your background is that you're half
japanese half french right
so was like what made you want to start
working into the in the anime industry
um actually in france we had at the
festion
first in the 90s and a show club
called club dorote and i actually
dorothy was a woman who bought a lot of
anime into dragon ball sensei
masonry cuckoo ranma and so when i was
little i watched those shows and
also i went often to japan with my
mother
and yeah i was used to watch a lot of
anime when i was
kid and i grew with manga also and so
yeah
i used to draw those characters when i
was little
and so i want at first i wanted to be a
mangaka
as does everyone i think every i think
every weeb has had that dream
one time in their lives
who's like who draws their first anime
characters like yeah
i'm on my way to be on show let's go
wait are you telling me connor that
you've never had like a like a story or
something that you've just like
fantasized about
no you've never you never fantasized as
a kid at all
probably but i thought it was like that
was like my thing right not sharing it
with other people
nice story you know what i mean you
never had a phase where you were like i
guess
though like you started watching anime
like a little bit of like
that's true 15
didn't get that whimsical phase of yeah
because i mean how old were you when you
like first like really
i guess like while knowing that this is
anime oh
i don't remember i think i would i think
the shock i had
was in in 98 when i
yeah watch uh princess monokey oh yeah
and
for the same i i didn't know what i'm
watching but it was beautiful
hairy and beautiful and i was just uh
nine nine nine yeah just nine and
also when i uh watched evangelion i was
just
10 or 11. what yeah how could you
understand anything
hey same here actually save me i'm glad
somebody i don't know if i was
understanding everything but oh there is
make out there's alien okay i have to
beat them
that's that's all you like understand
about ava when you're like yeah right
it's like
good guys bad guys i mean i'll be honest
i watched it last year and that's pretty
much my idea also
yeah i am the characters was 14 at the
story and i was 11 so
close enough yeah
i actually have a similar story about
like ava because ava is
the second proper anime that i watch
after discovering it was anime so the
first
the first anime i've i ever watched
knowing it was an anime was naruto
and how i found that was i was on a
random gaming forum and
you know it was back when having anime
avatars was
actually cool you know and
and i was like what are these avatars
that people have they they look really
cool and i found that
one one guy had this avatar that was the
show from the show called naruto and i'm
like oh this kind of looks like dragon
ball z
watch naruto [ __ ] loved it introduced
me to
anime properly um and then i went on the
same gaming forum and i made like an
anime thread
i was like guys this naruto thing's
awesome
can you guys recommend me something else
to watch like naruto
and some guy deadass goes you should
watch evangelion
totally like naruto totally so i i went
into evangelion i was like a 11 12 year
old thinking it was a shonen anime
and so for like the first i'd say half
of it
it could like maybe have like
past as i've shown him because you know
shinji could have still you know shinji
was still doing stuff
yeah and then the halfway point here and
then everyone just got
sad and depressed and i my 11 year old
mine was just like
why why are people like this this is
this is so stupid this is so
unrealistic i remember thinking as an 11
year old
this is the the writing of the show is
so bad because
the adults don't have their [ __ ]
together why is that so
why why don't the adults shove that [ __ ]
together this is so unrealistic
imagine like 11 year old guy coming up
to his mom being like mother what is
depression
i learned it in this show called
evangelion and now i'm just like oh
yeah so adults just nowhere else just
have their [ __ ] together
that's just life so you've always been
able to speak japanese since a young age
yes uh with my mother and uh so yes i
love i didn't i don't know if i can say
i learned but it
like you just know it yeah i just know
about it yeah i'll and
with anime with drama with movies and my
mother and some of my family
yeah but uh like i said it's you it's a
family language
right yeah so when you have to work
you use a another japanese language
which is
keigo oh god and so yes you it said
keigo is like very formal japanese very
former when you
have to spoke with your senpai with your
boss it's a different you have to put
your interrogator up and you're down
basically basically it's the bane of
every like person trying to learn
japanese right like that
it's like it's smooth sailing until you
hit keigo and then everyone's like
sailing until you hit keigo oh no oh
[ __ ] off
if you think it's hard now wait don't
you hit katie i've just given up on the
thought of evan yeah okay
i'm like i'm okay because i thought that
as well because i kind of was the same
thing right like yeah you know i don't
speak keigo to my parents i don't think
every kid does
so i had to learn keigo on the job when
i first like started
like you know at uh part-time jobs in
japan and i was like
i thought i knew japanese i'm told i had
to start using canva
it's just through every conception about
japanese out the window is there like
any comparison that's even close to
english with caico
um it's like oh man i don't know what is
there a comparison
would it be like trying to speak a very
old like very posh
kind of version yeah it's it's kind of
like the it's it's kind of like going
from
only learning internet slang to learning
shakespeare
yeah yeah it's it's like it's it's
basically another so you [ __ ]
have to learn to speak in cursive pretty
much yeah
we're literally like it's it's like a
shakespeare play you know when the
translation is on facebook
it's basically that i saw there was like
japanese cursive
is there like yeah i saw that someone
was writing japanese in cursive
or maybe like like calligraphy right no
no like legit like it was like a
doctor's note someone had showed me
and oh no dude like every time i have to
go to the doctors here i'm just like i
i might as well die but like i can't
read this note
it's good to know that that transcends
language that doctors just can't write
for [ __ ]
somehow that's just universal right yeah
i thought kanji was hard but you throw
in cursive kanji and i'm like come on
actually when you have some animators
you have some notes of my sample on
paper
yeah i i try to read it
because what did he wrong
it's like
so was it anime that i'm guessing it was
anime the reason you just
you've started to learn animation and
really at first i think um
no i so i wanted to be mangaka but
i was uh not good at school
not good at school and uh well i you
have a
lesson but i didn't listen the lesson i
was drawing manga
my notes and so
i went to another school
not a high school high school you could
learn about
communication aircraft in france
yeah in france i was born and raised in
france
and at first it was about communication
how to do cm
commercial and it was not pleasant but
i had to go this way to
go to animation schools right right
right yes
um i take to baccalaureate in french and
you say so uh
first degree i think oh bachelor yeah
you did a bachelor's degree in animation
in
yeah bachelor and after i can
went to uh animation schools oh wow oh
yeah
so how did it transition from than that
in france to
being in japan because i feel like
that's like a yes that's a big leap
right
at first when you were at the arts in
school
in france uh in france anime wasn't
so it's it was popular yeah but for
adults it's what kind of what kind of
child nonsense is this is this and
oh you should change some styles it's
not a good style
you have others who watching you
from up and change
the style too much a manga oh yeah
it's not a bad idea but it's manga yeah
and so
yeah i was okay i don't i have if i
draw manga it's bad things so i changed
my style
but when i uh but actually i wanted to
do manga style
yeah yeah i feel like in europe there
isn't the notion of
animation is especially anime looks for
children yeah
because i feel like everyone i spoke to
grew up in europe seems that way where
it's like oh
after i'm 16 i can't watch this child
stuff right
yeah it's it's every art student i know
like i have a cousin who's like
who's an art student and like she loves
anime but as soon as she started art
school
you you were just like it was looked
down upon to really draw an
anime art style so i don't know if it's
still the same i was getting bullied
everywhere
exactly right because like you you draw
anime and your art teacher would just be
like no no
please draw real art please some art
professor of art school oh you draw a
manga okay uh
i'm i will give you a bad note that's
called right yeah
you have to change yeah oh you have draw
some uh
american comics good
so yes not some equals by some
professor uh so teacher so
yeah it's it was kind of hard the first
time
because you're a bit lost okay i have to
change my style
but uh i when you met other people who
like what you like to yeah you have a
better communication and you know i want
to
do this i want to draw anime's time
because i want to be a weep
i want to follow my dreams and
so yeah and i found that to you there is
an animation school in france
and so i attempt to i went to animation
school but you learn disney way
right right right not a japanese way
of because japanese way is very
particular or you
you use economic economy of
the frame very smart
it's a smart way to use a japanese
animation in disney you have a lot of
budget so you can put a lot of frames
okay at the problem so basically disney
is just more drawings where
the japanese animation technique is more
let's say
optimized optimized
because of also the japanese animation
industry you have to do
one episode per week so
[Music]
um maybe in america they finished and
they delivered the episode
to the channel but in japan when you
broadcast the show it's not finished
yeah yeah you're trying to
yeah because i've noticed that a lot of
blu-ray releases
you have like retouches like jojo i
remember part four there's
some famous examples right of the side
by side where you can like there's a
website i think where you can
sweep the frame oh really cross and like
some of the character designs are
totally changed
in the blu-ray that's called dvd retakes
and
uh actually when you you saw you showed
the show on tv
yeah and so for people who want to buy
the dvd there is a plus and the plastic
bonus is a
better drawing the animation reading
more polished so is it is it is it like
the original drawing is thrown out and
they just remake it or do they improve
the original drawing
they improve or sometimes they redo it
oh wow oh wow so secret quality
for us this cat we cannot do a hundred
percent what we want it
right uh so let's redo it
yeah oh this one oh just mess up on the
eye so let's
redraw the eyes right okay okay wow yeah
i
i did find that funny actually because
like yeah i noticed that like because
you know i
i did uh when i did voice work for pop
team epic
i i did it on episode nine and when i
got the script for it
episode one had already aired so i was
like
is this gonna be out in time
because i always thought cause because i
always thought it worked like how in
american tv shows whereas like the
entire season is already getting
done and then they start releasing but
in japan they're just like no we gotta
do it now like
it's all real time right yeah yeah it
depends when the first
the first episode is broadcast uh
actually so the study you have
might have done already ten episodes
maybe if
the schedule was good right or if they
have done just a four episode
it would be hard yeah a lot of ten
episodes considered a good skit
yeah yeah exactly have you have you ever
been working up to the deadline where
you've been working on the show and
it's it's it's been airing like the next
day yeah
well it was for hiroka oh
i think uh season three
i was doing my gengar so yeah gengar is
the second step of the key animation
and uh what what is gengar involved okay
okay so
okay okay knows nothing about animation
so we're going to break it down
for now i will explain the process of
the fabrication of gengar okay
so you have the key animator me and i'm
i receive an offer of work by twitter or
by mail
by sometime yeah about twitter because a
lot of uh
assistant production are looking for
animators on twitter
and so for japan most of the japanese
animators they use twitter has a
portfolio or contacts yeah
and uh so hi i'm
i'm from this studio i have this project
uh the schedule is that
do you want to work on it so i look my
schedule
if it's okay if it's good match yeah
sure okay
so let's put a a date
for me do the meetings so okay this date
so i go to the schedule meet
the director episode and assistant
production who i
send mails and we are doing the the
meeting
for the sequence i have choose at first
they send me
a storyboard a storyboard is a little
comic
technical notes right right and i choose
my sequence
a sequence can be just like three cut
30 cuts 19 cats what what what's a cut
i cut it to one side one scene like one
continuous scene before
oh i see so the scene changes yeah so
you know when
in in live action when you film
something and then the camera cuts right
right obviously
in animation you don't have an entire
scene that you cut out of that's
pre-planned
right right that makes sense and so one
shin can be one second
or 10 seconds 30 seconds it depends
if there is a lot of seconds let's say
more walks
right right naturally and so
like so take an example okay i will
choose this sequence it's 10 cut
and so i go to the meeting so meeting
for with the
director and he's going to explain me
how
he see uh how he want
those 10 cuts make okay right and he
expect me
yeah for this cut i would like a a
rough animation a more action
is completely different to what sakura
in japanese actually is
yeah so in so in the anime community we
refer to sakuga as good animation right
yeah like lots of frames lots of flashy
animation but in japanese sakuga just
means
frames yeah
so it's kind of become like a buzz word
here right right
make sense like uh if you say anime in
japanese
so in japan monsters inc is technically
an anime yes
hello my anime list hello
so you had like 10 cuts of my hero
academia to do
yeah and different types of animation uh
different types of animation sometimes
just talkings yeah little actings
and sometimes some action kits and so i
do the
the meeting with the doctor so it takes
like 30 minutes
uh after so i have to do the first step
it's the layout
yeah so i'm going to explain what it is
yes okay okay
you're telling me words and i have no
idea tell me what the layout
layout is uh so you have the storyboard
i
i see you on the one scene and
i have to draw the background
with the character on it and all the
movement of the character just rough
very rough okay very rough
and also if there is a camera works i
have to
add it right and uh all
put the timing of this cut oh wow okay
so it's basically
like it's it's basically like the
storyboard but just a bit more
refined you see the character
what movement he will do just oh like
when you see like those outline sketches
yeah like that and
but it's you don't need to push it the
most so you have to
watch the drawings although you have to
know a bit of all the
what the character is the armor exactly
and when you finish that you so you send
it back
to the director the director will check
it
add some correction or the arm is a
too low more higher the expression
not sad more angry and after
those corrections by the director it
will go to the sakan
so uh sakuga kantoku is mean the
animation director okay okay and the
animation director
will put it your drawings more in model
so if you have see good drawing
it's because the sak can have put all
his gut on it
because the second in one episode there
is at least one or two
and here they have to check the 150 cuts
oh wow so so they basically make sure
that the characters kind of look the
same
yeah and consistent each round in fact
the
animators just uh draw a
rough diamond and if this diamond is
good quality
after the second can polish it right
right right
right so like so like how many like say
for like micro academy like an episode
of my academia like how many
different animators would be working on
like one episode for instance like
individual anime uh i
think uh maybe on average an average uh
uh at least ten animators could be good
if you but uh
you can see on the credits right how
many animators gengar in the podcast
right uh harmonies animators sometimes
you have
15 animators or sometimes you have what
it's called one man
army just one guy
one guy
an entire 24-minute episode yeah and the
dusk
guys are coral monsters
just like red like just destroyed their
wrists are just like this thing
they're very very fast in
like you see this is a japanese
animation when you see a
veteran animator who yeah show you
there's one guy doing it all
it's like it's like that scene from
hunter hunter where the guy returns from
like
being up in the mountains for like 10
years or something
and it just shows everyone how it's done
and everyone becomes its disciples
take me like one day you can do it in
one hour oh my god wow some people have
too much talent
because you have also me i'm just i'm
31 yeah right and guy my senpai
it's like 31 years of experience in
animation
oh my god that's like jim's a baby so
five years in the anime industry is like
nothing it's nothing wow oh my god
we'll have you back on in 20 years
[Laughter]
it's like yes i can do a cut in an hour
now whatever so
sorry going back earlier as well even
way over earlier in the conversation um
i guess
uh you said you you learned in france
and uh i am curious because you
we jump back into talking about anime
how did you then make the leap to when
you're done with art school
in yeah uh japan because um
was a and you mentioned school we have
to then do internship
and so i asked my school it was possible
to
go to japan to do my internship they
said yes if you
find your the studio by yourself
okay and so i my first internship
was a oh boy 10 years ago
2011 and uh so
i have sent a lot of mails yeah yeah
20 25 bringing out the keigo
he's a good man my mother helped me
i've been there for the proper firms and
my portfolio
and uh so yeah i had just five answers
and four no yeah and one yes
oh and that's all you need yeah so
at least they're courteous enough to
reply with a no because most job
interviews or most job
places i applied so if i know it's just
not hearing back yeah
and i was so happy uh
but in march you had the earthquake
and so the studio asked me do you really
want to come to japan
i i didn't know what will future will be
for me and for me it was a unique chance
so i said yeah definitely yeah and the
studio was a telecom animation film
okay they have made a a castle of
cagliostro
i think most recently didn't they make a
tower of god
yes yes yes i think that's the most
recent one i remember them making
this episode is sponsored by expressvpn
you know what i like doing gentlemen
what [ __ ] especially [ __ ]
privately
that's a controversial take i know now
imagine if you just couldn't [ __ ]
privately and your door was always open
well that's what it's like not using
expressvpn i actually like
shooting with the door open i don't
did you know that your internet service
provider like comcast or verizon knows
every single website you visit now
that's not cool
and what's worse is that they can sell
this information to ad companies and
tech giants who will use your data to
target
you luckily expressvpn can put a stop to
that it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone wow i use
expressvpn on all my devices it works on
everything phones laptops even routers
yes i said routers because that's how i
was taught to say it
is it route or router i say router i
said router i'm i'm root as well i just
said who to gang right
so everyone who shares your wi-fi can
still be protected even if they don't
have
expressvpn i've put it on my bidet issue
no but i you know i'd like to if i could
and the best part is using expressvpn is
as easy
as closing the bathroom door which i
don't do you just fire up the app
click the button and you're protected
express vpn is the world's number one
rated vpn by cnet wired the verge and
countless others
so if you're like me and believe your
online activity is your
business
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
trash taste today that's expressvpn.com
trash chase and you can get an extra
three
months for free that's expressvpn.com
trash taste links down in the
description below thank you for the
sponsor back to the video
so what did you have to do at your
internship what was that like so
at first they i have some
one no two weeks of experience
of how to do a walk how a characters
do a rotation of the head so exercise
it will be exercised on paper okay and
so at first i oh i know that
but i like i said i know the western
the disney way i didn't know the
japanese
way with a um less frame
with just some key pause and after you
do the in-betweens
but uh i had the key pauses and i have
to clean up
these key positions and do the in
between frames so
the in-between frames are i assume as
they say right
in the name right you want you want to
explain explain
this is one yeah two
right for a punch one right two right
but
for uh there need some in-betweens
to maybe just leaky paws
uh in betweens right in between
keepers and those are the in-betweens
are normally
not as polished as the uh the
so the in-betweens it's uh you have to
take the
the two keepers and to layer them layer
them and
you do the in-betweens and like that oh
okay yeah basically like the plug-in in
after effects that people put over that
animate make it 60 fps but someone's
actually doing that themselves that's
right
that's why i can describe it in japan we
are
uh 24 fps yeah
and that's the the in-between frames are
normally given to like interns and
yes and first uh when you start you
start as a dog
and you say so the ogre is moving it's
mean
moving pictures but uh it's mean in
between
in japan and so i have done this for two
weeks and after
just two weeks so they put me on uh
productions
oh wow and it was two weeks into your
internship wow
yeah two weeks of exercise and the last
uh
two months and a half it was on the
production of lupine
i thought you'd be getting coffee or
something for the years
two weeks then working on lupone really
put you to work
so it was a two to two weeks of exercise
and after
two months and half on lupine it was a
tv special so a tv show and
yes it was my first experience and so i
met a lot of
famous animators a lot of veterans and
the stuff was very nice to me it was at
mitaka
at this moment
and yes the stuff was very nice they
were they was wondering
where why do you why
uh no and yeah i wanted to or got
bothered boy i want to
i want to work in japan yeah you want to
be an animator for anime man i feel bad
for our intern now
like i'm well i'm sorry ashley like
hearing the story you know
but uh so and i had a meta senpai
a french senpai who my name um
christopher
and uh and he said me that uh
take a time and uh walk very late
and people when you walk very late there
are less centimeters but the boss is not
here
and so animators are more
they're more free to speak to you right
right more socializing
yeah at night or you work harder
very night uh late uh what are you doing
i feel like there must be a bonding
experience right because you're staying
up late together
exactly uh when most of my good
animated friends was because uh
yes we work we've period
eight o'clock of the morning because we
work hard we didn't slept
and yo you know i'm a brother in arm
so you literally just sent an email to a
company yeah and then
you flew to japan yeah and wow
what time frame was it from you sending
that email to the company to you being
in japan
and working on lupin the third yeah uh
so
i sent the mail in january they said
okay
and so i went in june and um
six six months that's crazy but uh
yes but i i was pretty lucky because
the director said yes and now the
director is not
no more working at telecom animation
right right because
he's now in toy uh and yes so it was
cool
and so this was my first experience in
the japanese animation industry it was
10 years ago
and so i went to another animation
school
and to this animation school i had to
have the occasion to do a summer school
at goblin
they called it's a french famous school
for animation
and i have met uh thomas romer
he's very famous because he's maybe the
the pop of the french animators in japan
and also because he's very famous uh he
redrew
his kids drawings oh wow oh
i might have that sounds familiar that
sounds very familiar
that sounds like he blew up on reddit or
something right
he kissed drew and he picked the picture
of his kid and redraw it
has a professional way yeah that sounds
that sounds very familiar yeah
and i met him at uh at this summer
school
and i he gave me i talk a bit
with him and he gave me uh his uh
his cards business cards and
connection is very important like i said
this summer's cool i could do it because
i'm in fact the director of telecom
animation school was
doing a summer school at goblin but he
needed a translator
and he called me okay you can help me
right right right
and that's why the first the first way
to find a contact is very difficult but
when you have one
he can introduce you to someone else's
door opens yeah
that's what it is with live with like
the anime industry is that like it's
only
so big yeah yeah so once you know one
person yeah
it's just the hardest the hard part is
getting in yeah
but everyone i've met who's working in
the anime industry especially if they're
a foreigner
they've just had like that one lucky paw
off like
just just like that one lucky in and
once they brought that in as your
animators
it's the first time it's difficult to
entry but after it's to stay also
yeah i will explain later but so
yeah i so i sent a mail at a term aroma
and toma roman was working at
this time at a satellite so they are
very famous
for the series macros and the animation
studio
yeah yeah they uh they made log horizon
as well season
one of the seasons
and so uh
i could manage to do a four months
internship at satellites
wow and but the it was very different of
telecom
so it was a bit more colder a bit more
rush uh hurry up hurry up and
and uh take home the animators were
coming at 10
and living at night like at 10 also but
uh at satellite everybody was coming in
the afternoon
two or four and was working at
6 00 a.m jesus
definitely a lot more like hardcore i
guess like what i want to ask is like
kind of going back to the loop and the
third thing like
i assume you like watched the tv show
when i like after it came out right like
i've always wanted to know like as an
animator like how does it feel to see
something that you drew be animated on
tv because like i can't imagine what
that's like right so
sometimes you oh [ __ ] i screw up
and uh now i oh it's fine
uh like the odd i managed to do
something good but
when some few weeks passed
look at it again you're not very
satisfied
yeah that's how you know you've grown
right yeah yeah
the way of uh to grow our drawings is
very difficult because it's
not like that it's like stairs
right right and sometimes there is a
long
flat momentum you don't progress through
yeah
and yeah you can it's uh yeah you fight
against you
and be to improv and sometimes you can
depress
sometimes but i'm sure there's been
moments where you know there was like a
cut
oh yeah it was really good you're just
like yeah i did that yeah yeah there is
this moment and
when you have this moment it's the
moment ah man animation is cool
i think it's the same for us when we
make like a youtube video sometimes we
just feel like we've stagnated in
content and sometimes how do i beat this
yeah
sometimes we put out that one banger
video and like yeah this is why i do
youtube
you hate your job for the rest of the
time and also when you can talk
animation with your senpai or your
co-workers
is very good and how they share the same
likes
their way of thinking and animation is
the same as me
yeah it's a cool and so talking about
animation with your senpai and
you learn a lot of history of other
famous show
at this point when they've done this
episode there was broken
yeah right but they managed to succeed
i got to ask what's the first show where
you got that you were given that you
were like
really really excited for like like i'm
like when you realize oh i'm working on
this show
really this show was what was the first
time i got a super boring dragon ball oh
of course of course i bet it was
when i was little i was working dragon
ball of goku i was
emitting and
so i had so so yeah dragon ball i had
the chance
to work on it because my senpai i i
i was at epico at this moment and i
had started as key animator
and uh yeah so we we skipped a lot of
years of uh
graffinica while i was in between so
when i was at yapiko my senpai wanted to
work on
dragon ball super the series but
so we had our another senpai who had
worked on the
resurrection of f and previous
movie of dragon ball super oh okay
resurrection and his name is
shimizu
shimon
he's the character designer of megalo
box oh
[ __ ] okay and he so he introduced us
to uh toei uh hey those french people
want to work on dragons
and so today uh uh met us and uh
okay so we have this episode you have a
vegeta and
goku who had to fight these uh
and not remember the name of the man
so someone's just like these guys want
to work on dragon ball and toys
literally like yeah sure
well he he uh we had a recommendation
okay so at first let's do the series uh
and if the series was good okay maybe
you can walk
do more right yeah on the movie because
we and the movie wasn't
announced at this moment right right
right and so okay let's uh let's work on
the episode
but when they send us the storyboard and
the schedule
there was not a good match because uh it
was at the end of
december and most of the french people
was going back to
christmas christmas and so ask sorry can
you we
can you give us another story about the
fans episode
and oh okay um oh by the way
how about the movie uh
sure just casually throw that isn't it
they tested you out on the movie
yeah oh my god what what a trial run
imagine that and it was the first time
i'm drawing i was doing genga
on a movie oh my gosh so i had some
pressure
because i'm pressured
you know that dragon ball fans are can
be
don't we we've talked about it before
we've really talked about dragons
are the dragon balls the same in dragon
ball fans the same in japan like they
are the west or you talk about the west
i i don't know some people can say bad
things
i think it's different when an animator
worked on the movie
i know so i was uh i have
had the pressure but i was happy man i'm
walking on dragon ball
and well yes it's cool and so when i was
doing
my drawings on dragon boy i was putting
chad
i was sleeping at the schedule but i was
listening dragon ball and
hyping yourself up yes and i had my
buddy uh media with showy
who was uh who we slept at the studio
and uh doing our dragon balls uh
oh my god so you went from being an
intern to working on lupon and then
being an in-betweener to just going
straight into the dragon ball super no
no no of course not
so i might have done my internship at
telecom animation theme at satellite so
i have done two internships
okay uh six months or if you
put put it all together and uh
when i finished my school i said okay i
have the two internship
i know it's hard that's a telecom it was
a good mood
at the satellite it was more cold and
you have to more hurry
and you are paid also by frame so the
the money [ __ ] yeah it's per frame here
rather than per day am i allowed to ask
you what that might be a frame uh well
when you're in betweener
you are paid like a two euros per frame
two euros per frame
holy [ __ ] oh my god so what are you
doing what is that
so you would draw a friend go to family
mart get a sandwich and you just
like that it's like it's like it's like
three or four bucks
us that's like before tax right
uh yeah oh my i assume you wouldn't even
make enough to go for the tax cuts
when you take a drink you okay can i
board
buy maybe yes oh i have to do more
frames
so so you're so you're you're making a a
choice
i need to draw more so i can eat and
drink yeah okay so
how how long would you say it takes you
to do a frame
it depends it depends the frame can be
just five minutes
right right uh some frame can took you
two three hours
oh my that's pretty i mean
i mean this has been a hot button topic
in the industry for a while yeah i think
i think a lot of people do talk about
that animators get paid
just hearing it from natural animated
just you know and
also because nowadays the the anime
getting more details the more
more lines has the price gone up more
sakura
uh it was 50 years ago uh
when you draw one frame you can
eat on ramen yeah right but the rate of
the life
increase but the
so now if you want to eat a ramen you
have at least
do a five or six frame oh my gosh so
if you don't have me asking when did
your internship initially how much were
you getting paid for that and you were
were you living off just
uh at the first internship i wasn't paid
oh wow yeah
but the second internship i was paid so
it really was like a passion
yes it was a patient thing then i was
knowing that
internship you are paid or not but i
i was paid so by frame for my internship
at satellite
and so i knew okay it would be hard
so i tried to do my best but yeah i was
just afford my one month my best record
when i was in an internship it was just
150
under the frames yeah so it was like 300
yeah oh my god for a month
and a specialized job as well so this
was my internship and so it was on paper
so wait the guy who was probably
cleaning the toilets at the studio is
probably getting paid more than
that yeah honestly it's probably
actually if you walk a company um
yeah like not trying to diminish any
jobs but like i mean you know
cleaning a toilet is not a specialist
mcdonald's
especially considering how art school
was like one of the most
expensive schools i cannot go trying to
belittle any of the jobs we need those
jobs but like yeah the fact that it is a
specialized job
yeah yeah you can do your best was 300
bro it was my internship okay so it was
that's not enough to live right and yeah
so but uh like i said i
um my mother japanese i had a family in
japan
in tokyo so yes it was cool because my
family
i was living in the house of my uh
grandmother so it was a cool
oh okay that's nice that's it or
anything yes
because i was i had luck but if i so i
was thinking
man if for foreign people if you don't
have family
yeah i was able to say like like did you
have friends who didn't have family here
who
uh yeah but uh better they uh
get a better they could negotiate better
than me right
right right so that's why you have to uh
now
the good advice is uh you have to
look a the good studio to
take a lot of information of each study
oh how do they pay
at satellite it was a yeah it's but it
was just an internship so
you i cannot take example of satellite
but i more example on graphinica
the studio i i was doing in between but
digital in between
right right right digital i was more
quicker
okay but that was the pay the same the
pay was the same
but the pay was the same but uh we had a
cote cue
uh it's mean uh so you have a little
fixed amount of salary and it was at
least
400 euros a month a month okay
and if you and they ask you to do
uh 300 frames per month it was
at least do 300 frames at least 300
frames a month yes
wow and so when you success to do 300 i
think you
get yourself 300 frames 2 euros
you have 600 plus the fix salary
600 600 a month yeah 600 frames a month
so 600 to 200
yeah so you can last have a thousand to
500
euros for an internship that's probably
like fifteen hundred dollars that's
probably not bad
yeah this wasn't an internship this was
a walk
okay that kind of sucks okay well
what's wayleen's face over there is like
sweating right now
so yes and so most of my co-workers
and i have i'm working um i'm living
with
uh at my parents house i'm
living with a sharehouse master
yes so you you have to pay attention
about
your money how you spend it's not a
glamorous lifestyle no you
you you you don't leave your survivor
right yeah yeah
yeah i think a lot of people sometimes
would like i remember people can't do
because i'll be like with like uh i mean
by anime expert i was with trigger and
they were like oh they want to job at
trigger and i'm like
like do you really want a job where like
you really have to work your ass
what are your workouts like if you don't
mind me asking graffinica
yeah so i start at um
at 10 and uh and it depends
about the deadlines and you have some
time i arrived
and there is a lot of cuts and my senpai
oh you have to finish this for
this evening yeah at eight okay i okay
would you so i don't eat lunch
at lunch very opposite yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and sometimes i have oh some good
cut
i want to do this please let me do this
okay just
learn it in three days oh [ __ ] i
i would say because i want it was
pokemon guys
so i wanted to walk pokemon uh and yeah
but you're making exceptions you're like
i like pokemon yeah i ruined my life for
probably
it was brew blue yeah it was a
pokemon generation on youtube so oh cool
wow oh that one
yeah yeah yeah and it was blue with uh
in japanese you say kamek so mad i don't
know in english
toys and so there's french names as well
isn't there french localized names
french names
that's way more about us well i i
learned about that apparently the french
locations were like really well done for
pokemon apparently
it was really really well done and all
the names were like really uh well
thought out and to do with like
a mix of japanese and french mythology
that's awesome wow that is like the very
opposite of european lifestyle where
it's like oh it's five
oh the building's on fire well yeah i'm
clogged i'm going yeah
it's like this yeah so yeah yeah
yeah in between you have to be
passionate and you have to love that
animation
yeah and also it depends what kind of
experience you want if it's
just oh i want to work just once
for this show or naruto on one piece i
don't know
or there oh i was just a one who two
years experience in japan
ooh no i wanted to have a career in
japan so
right it depends what experience you
want to experience so you often find
people coming to the companies like i
only want to be here for a year or two
then go back yeah
so sometimes you have sometimes some
people have came in japan and
they had some homesick yeah because it
was the first time they came in japan
and the food didn't go well and
they they couldn't speak japanese
so yeah so the most and english was
so-so so yes are you difficult to make
some friends and
so yes you you you still
hang around with the same people so
right it's just completely different
lifestyle
yeah did you know english before you
came to japan yeah
i was leaning learning english at school
so
yeah i got asked because you grew up in
france yeah and
moving you you know about you know how
much well
you were telling us earlier about how
much more you can get paid doing the
same job
being in france and also having let's
say
less work hours as well what made you
decide to
give that up and move to japan and
have like a yeah because when i uh tell
my
my story of my internship uh
to my friends can you do you really want
to go to japan issue because
i mean i don't want i want to i want to
have a life i
i could completely understand you know
yeah there is no
this is the right way
you have a everybody has his way of
doing it
doing it and in my case i wanted to work
in
japanese animation industry because i
i like animation i like manga
and yes there is something
kind of canadian a bit sorry majorities
but yeah yeah but uh
yeah it's the way to learn also
yes it's kind of a bit like this it's
just purely passion
yeah it just sounds like you you are
doing it purely for the past yeah i was
going to say for that pay you better be
passionate
so but uh yes but i mean animation
the two three years are hard so
if you want to do a career in japan so
you have to speak japanese
yes you you can manage to to work in
japan
with english but just some few studio
will open the doors because
they have a translator or not and but if
you can speak japanese
more open doors will offer too yeah and
as we've established
like you know from your stories is that
you know getting to know the people as
well
it just takes you so far it really does
seem that like if you do speak japanese
it's like way easier to get into the
anime industry than i think people
make it out to be yeah it's definitely
an easy mode isn't it yeah
i mean it's it's the same moving to any
country and enjoying joining their
industry right
i i think because you almost find people
put like the anime industry on like a
pedestal right
yeah like it's the anime industry it's
mythical it's japanese we don't know
what happens
right but then when you talk to people
it's like oh yeah i get paid like two
euros a frame
i think you know like going back to the
the story of the guy who you know
came up and said like that he wanted to
work a trigger like yeah yeah guarantee
he has
no idea no idea what it's like to
actually working through it's like it's
like six o'clock
he's like ready to go home and
everyone's like no no it's four more
hours yeah
because yes in japan you have the django
yeah and
uh you so you just you say oh you can
leave the studio at eight but nobody
live at eight
exactly exactly you can leave it and
then you
yeah the clock out times in japanese
companies is not
an official clock out yeah i mean it's
like a suggested yeah
but yeah so so when i was
working at graphene cup and first i in
my mind i say
one year we see how one year
will be if it's too hard i will go back
to france and
yeah first faster one year and
okay i think i can do one yen plus one
like
my five years and yes i
still i yeah and now i have found a good
studio for c
i learn a lot of from my same pies and
yeah i i can do
more do more yeah
how much longer do you think though
because you you're you said you're 31
right yeah still doing all-nighters
uh yeah crunch time but you cannot yeah
i was i was gonna say because like i've
just hit my 30s as well and
man all-nighters they they are def they
definitely hit different yeah
your body in my 30s and i can't do all
nighters anymore because when you're 22
oh
yeah a few cans of red bull it's you
yeah easy
like 48 hours yeah when i was younger
getting uh your drink
at night and you go to work the other
day yeah it was okay no
now it's like oh it's 11 pm [ __ ] i'm
trying i definitely do find that my
willpower is
over exerting my body i'm like no i can
do this yeah i'm dying
so yeah so you have to push yourself and
like i said
um so it's a lot of hours you are
sitting
yeah yeah and sometimes i was i don't
think i feel well because
i had a lot of pain in my feet
[Applause]
because i was always sitting sitting and
so the the
had an amount of water water blood on my
ankles were
swollen oh my god so that's like that's
that's what happens you know when you're
like sitting in a plane for a long time
oh i guess it is good from that and so i
had to oh
to get up and walk because it's about
2.4
this episode of trista is sponsored by
honey yes we all shop online yes and
we've seen that promo code field that
taunts us
at the checkout well thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the goddamn past yes
honey is a free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best ones it finds
to your card supporting over 30 000
stores online they range from sites that
have tech and gaming products to popular
fashion brands and even food delivery
that's
epic you know what connor i actually
took your advice and i bought myself a
dyson
i knew it can't do that i don't know
suction power it was the best
decision it was the best decision of my
life i even saved
twenty dollars on it get out of here get
out of here that's a lot of money i mean
considering the price of those damn
things you better be saving some money
and thanks to honey
for enabling us to save money on our
vacuums for the good suck imagine it
you're shopping on
your favorite website i know what it is
don't tell me when you're at the
checkout
honey automatically searches for all the
best coupons all you need to do is click
apply coupons and it will find it if
honey finds a working coupon your watch
as the prices just
drop honey has found it's over 17
million members over two
billion dollars in savings not a million
billion and that's a lot of gacha money
that i could
put into this stop if you already don't
have honey you could be straight up
missing on some free
savings wow it's literally free to
install and it takes seconds guys
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting the boys
i like that so you can get honey free
today at joinhoney.com
trash taste that's join honey.com trash
taste back to the episode
yeah i guess uh going off of that i want
to ask like you know obviously you draw
god knows how many hours per day right
like i'm sure you've run into like you
know
injuries and like wrist problems like is
there like certain stuff that you do to
like make sure you don't hurt yourself
well you have to i have to do some
stretch yeah i have a message ball
to make for my hands to stretch like
that or
do you wear like those like wrist guards
that i see some animators wearing uh
no not me uh but uh yeah every
one two hours i have to do some stretch
because sitting
and you have to also have a good seat
you could see do you have a good gamer
chair at home
i don't remember the brown but yeah but
in fact i'm walking on tablet
yeah so and furniture unfortunately i
cannot be like that oh you're like
hunched over right
don't forget the microphone by the way
yeah sorry
um i guess it's the same same kind of
precautions a lot of
let's say like like professional gamers
and esports athletes have to go through
because
you you're doing a lot of movements like
carpal tunnel right yeah
yeah so if sometimes i have pain here
oh no message uh so yeah so
in fact animators have to do sports also
because so i
sometimes went to gold gym with my
friend
medi and to do some exercise
right and because uh yes you los you
lose muscles
yeah yeah yeah i definitely feel doing
youtube as well because i'm sat at my
desk all day
yeah i got to do something with the
coroner so now you
yeah you don't you don't leave much you
don't move much yeah
yes to the desk to the fridge right yeah
as as like a teenager sitting at your
desk playing video games
all day and all night or whatever you
never think about oh
what are the ergonomics right now you
know you never you never think about
what part of my body am i injuring yeah
exactly i did feel bad because when i
use i used to play games like
you know pretty much from after school
until i went to bed yeah and i never had
any problems and my other friend would
play like two hours a night if he was
lucky and he got carpal tunnel oh geez
and i was like you're weak real gamer
you ain't a pro gamer look at the look
at those weak wrists
get out of here those aren't gamers
get some real thumbs i was just like
worried i'm like why are my wrists not
giving in
this man's are giving in
natural selection like shows you in the
wrong way you know my kid is going to
have like
jacked wrists like natural selection is
gonna
kick in like oh my god
so yeah so most of when you are young
you can stay
more longer just at your work hard but
when you get older
you have now a family kids and you can't
afford to just stay yeah
yeah go back to to home and well no no
one of your senpai's can draw so fast
they need to
otherwise that's the other and they was
trained to so
right and just this pressure and these
those deadlines make them more uh faster
and faster but and good you have the
quality
but sometimes when you you know not have
a much experience you have to get faster
and sometimes you have to sacrifice the
quality
yeah and uh i i suppose are those the
scenes that
kind of always get memed on on twitter
and social media and stuff like that yes
and also you have you know those things
well they was a a bit a mess
uh some because of the communication
wasn't good or wizard
production the animator didn't have time
to do it
or the animator couldn't do it okay we
have nobody
okay we'll give it to china korea to do
it and
and china oh we don't have time we have
to speed it
right that makes sense seven deadly
scene this depends
also which studio will do it right
because sometimes you have a
gloss so for example if you have statue
a
we'll do all the episodes of 12 episode
but oh
we don't have much time we have to do we
will do just a 10 episode and
the two other will be done by different
schedule so they will ask to study b and
c
to do each one episode and
if a b and c don't have the good stuff
it looks bad you have some
accident and also more than the studio
you
should more look just tough the stuff
the studio is like a shell
yeah yeah the statue will give a good
good environment
to for a good working place for the
animators and a good assistant
productions
but all the skills and all the the stuff
will be all in freelance so it's a
studio who
uh okay if you we you can do this
project
and we can give you a good working place
yeah can you because i've always
wondered because
you know there's there's always like the
meme in our community where if
if an episode is animated well versus an
episode that's animated bad
we always talk about like oh it's it's
the budget you know they're not
giving enough budget but like how like
how
how true is that how is that actually
reflected or like is it
do they have is it all about the staff
that they can hire and the staff there's
also the staff a lot of things in fact
you have also the budget but for example
you have an episode
you have a lot of action a lot of
movement actually one episode it's a
350 cuts but for some
a lot of heavy episodes a lot of action
epic episode can have a 500 cuts right
so
for this episode it will be more
expensive driving per car
yeah but so for the next episode you
have to
adjust this right right right
so so if you had the climax on episode 7
so maybe episode 8 will be more cool
right and you talked about some
animators being more experienced and
more skilled and like
have making a name for themselves can
they um can they negotiate a higher
price per cut yeah yeah actually yeah so
uh
so the rate of the cut is uh
when you when you have the offer they
said you the rate of the cut
is this so most of the series is uh 4500
yen i don't know 45 45 yeah
for one cup one cut okay okay so one cut
can
take you like one hour one day two days
oh
oh gosh five dollars for two days of
work
or sometimes he can take you uh one week
i know a great website called fiverr you
might
so um so like that you you can ask
excuse me uh you you you
try to negotiate yeah yeah
my rent is this much uh you
have to negotiate for this cat it's a
bit heavy cut can you
put it twice or two right right twice
the price or
three times the price please uh you have
to negotiate and
sometimes if you are very very famous
like
we call this a super animator like a
one-man army yeah right you say my rate
is this
okay okay they want you yeah yeah they
want you because you're gonna you
gotta put your dick on you yeah you have
now and if you have very famous mate i'm
acquiring like a veteran and major
they have the name value or because in
the show people want to look it
right so that's kind of how like it
works with like youtubers too right this
is like
if you're a famous youtuber that has so
much years of experience then you can
just be like yeah you know
honestly if you've made a name for
yourself you deserve a higher
right actually we can say that it's a
bit like a soccer
teams uh when you oh i want to one
ronaldo or you want to messy yeah
you got to pay the money right yeah is
that why whenever you see
like the climax of a big scene
especially in like some shown in anime
or like some big
you always see the same names animating
uh same
names yes all some new ones and because
yeah
some you you cannot read all only of
some few names you have to find
new talent yeah and are they constantly
looking for new animators
always always right yeah yeah i yeah i
guess it's because if you're not getting
paid like a lot it's hard to find
yeah so do it right yeah uh actually if
you
too expensive so okay we don't have the
budget sorry so
we are going to find someone else you
mentioned twitter as well is that how
they find a lot of the the newer talent
yeah twitter also because uh now on
twitter i think you know the web
generation
yeah some quite uh foreign animes
animators
who yeah welcome pretty pretty much
i'm just wondering so is there this much
of a shortage of animators in japan that
they
have to look literally on twitter
they're doing what we do and just
browsing twitter and being like you you
seem to have a guy
or by recommendation by uh by
other senpai oh i had work with this
young guy
he's pretty scared for or
i will have work with this we had some
problem but
you can manage to work on it so you have
a
dependency if you work with a friend
people
you you know that they're learning by
themselves
by themselves and they're doing all the
the best that they want
and they accept the amount of money and
so
if they they there is accident it's
normal because they are leaning by their
self
and yeah you have to teach them how to
get better yeah yeah yeah because i
actually have like an artist friend
who used to like draw stuff for me years
ago yeah i ended up being an animator
for black clover
yeah samir like i i had a like uh
an artist who i was following an
animator and then they just showed up
working on
sword art online yeah right yeah shout
out to kate shout out to k animations
yeah it's just
weird how that like i didn't think like
i'd always heard of like the webgen
animators right yeah we call them but
like i've never actually like
seen it happen so when i saw it happen i
was like oh wow they actually use
twitter as like a formal
auditioning yeah yeah exactly actually i
think the
the flashpoint we can take like that was
uh maybe
at uh boruto
what is that 65 oh you have uh oh
that fight yeah oh it's the uh sasuke
versus
sasuke naruto versus yeah yeah and in
fact
the episode director was a sikhi co-son
and he is a chinese guy who
success to
call a lot of foreign animators and he
was by himself doing the assistant
projection by himself or trying to
contact a lot of animators check their
car to put some correction
and i think he has spent two months
at the studio but because of
him he could manage a lot of animators
to work on this episode
and the episode 65 of balto was a master
class yeah i mean that was
my favorite fight i've seen the fight i
don't
know anything but i i haven't seen i
haven't seen borrowed so i've just seen
that fight actually and that was by far
like the best fight
of the year in my opinion right and with
this
explicit it's proved okay foreign
animators can also work
on japanese animation but you have
problems also of about communication
you have some you have uh staff who
have to speak english or if they can
speak japanese it's okay
or sometimes you have some mistakes by
them but
yes it's uh if you work with foreign
some it's happen but uh if you
correct them and they will do their best
to uh
what would you say is the best way for
let's say a young animator
to get involved in the anime industry
now well now like i said it depends the
experience you want if
you want just walk ah we just want to
work on one piece
just once okay so twitter will be okay
i think uh or i want just a one year
experience uh
so i okay see if you want to come to
japan
you have to find a studio could prove
you a visa right
you couldn't believe a lot of groups
yeah yeah yeah yeah and if you want a
career
i want to work in japan i want to live
in japan i want to marry the
japanese girl i want to i want that
ideal weave and so all of you to assume
you're going to have enough time and
money to marry a japanese girl as an
animator
i was thinking of asking i don't know
how personal is because you mentioned
that like obviously the senpais they
have a family and whatnot
how the [ __ ] does anyone date who's an
animal because
it sounds like you guys never leave the
office how do you do it you bring them
to the office you're like hold on i'm
gonna do a keyframe i'll answer that
question
yes a bit like that have you ever
brought a date to the office
but um actually yes so i'm working at
the studio and also i'm
so sometimes i'm working on two shows at
the same time so i'm working on the
movie and sometimes
again how do you find the time because
unless you're dating like
another key animator right yeah yo she's
turn blocks down
she's like three tables away actually i
i prefer
not data to the workplace
right about animations for
going to a bit kill my passion i will
say i prefer to
talk other things uh so oh yeah of
course
yeah you have the love for your life
revolving around yeah i'm sure you want
to break because i'm
i'm thinking animation i i walk
animation i [ __ ] animation
well that's the thing right it's like
you're doing so much with animation so
it's like
how do you find time to be like you know
what i'm going to today i'm just going
to go out of town just you know
did you get do you get a lot of down
time yes yes yes because
now like i said um uh so the few years
hard but you after you can manage
with the statue to have a course okay
and kosoku is mean uh
a fixed contract you can say and you can
get paid per month
okay all right but this is
so better you you have to prove yourself
okay yeah i
so you at first you have to prove
yourself yeah
this is so bizarre because yeah because
like i said here you
or all those uh salary of all those
money is by
surprise yeah you don't sign contracts
oh really yes or you get paid this
amount
but you say nothing is just by speaking
so it's all verbal yes or by me do you
get it do you get it like in cash or
like what like you said
uh bank oh my god
but that kind of goes completely against
what we talked about with like twitter
artists right yeah
like you have to like sign a contract
and like get an nda and all that [ __ ]
just to like protect your id
where in japan it's just like yeah we
promise we'll give you this
i have more security buying something
off ebay yes jesus christ
you don't sign nda in japan yeah i think
you can come here and talk about the
things that you know technically
yeah i mean you were telling it's all
based on the trust system is is this
true
even for when they like contact a random
twitter
animator and what and ask them to work
on a new project they it's not not under
nda or anything like that
they trust you so so the animator who
could say no and be like
guys i know the next movie that's coming
out yeah i'm like that's oh
my god how is that like a leak every
week
because it's the trust of uh
um animate the trust of the the schedule
on the animators
and if you have some links but you get
just blacklisted
yeah sure and if you get basic by you'd
find no more works yeah yeah so yeah
it's you
that's crazy it's up to you don't [ __ ]
it up
yeah i'm surprised there hasn't been
like just one person
one one rogue animator hasn't popped up
in the entire history of anime yeah
that's that's impressive
well if you mess up you send um big
names so
oh what did you done yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
jesus scary because i i guess it would
make sense because a lot of people
look up to the directors right and the
people in charge so i doubt they were
trying
i guess it'd be like backstabbing your
idol yeah right the thing that you the
thing you love right
now unless that makes sense i guess uh
do you want to talk about the thing that
all three of us have been wanting to ask
yeah i i i mean
as an animator on twitter and everything
like that your it matters yeah
your opinion your opinion your opinion
matters our opinion doesn't mean [ __ ]
your opinion on the other hand it means
a lot yeah like how do you feel about
you know artists and animators getting
backlash
after an episode has aired for example
attack on titan yeah i'm going to say it
for some reason people are very very
angry and have been sending even i think
death threats yeah
just like directors and animators on
twitter and stuff like that
does that scare you or anything like
that working on projects well if i had
those kind of
threats it would be oh i messed up but
no no no no you should actually
in my case if i it's just twitter
internet i
don't have time to bother about that i
have to consider it in my drawings
exactly so yeah but for people who gave
all the guts didn't sleep managed to
to deliver the episode and receive all
the stretches
it's a bit it's not very hard
to deal with threats yeah and hard work
yeah and i think that most of you
animators nodes are working up i
couldn't
done this this is good well but i
managed to
deliver the episode and they know their
level and they want to progress too good
yeah yeah everybody wants to do a good
episode want to make a quality
right but you have to manage it with the
amount of schedule the amount of money
and it's uh yes it's very hard and
sometimes you
in animation a good
schedule a good something going well
doesn't exist
in mission you have a lot of problems
teeny problems you have to adjust
right right it's not just like the
problem of like you know the single
animator yeah
it's like there's a lot of things that
the animator probably has to juggle but
like
if i like you know both say for example
like i i would maybe understand a little
more if even the animator
looked at what they did and was like
yeah that wasn't my best work
but this is a tag on time we're talking
yeah and it's been pretty amazing so far
yeah you've been following the episodes
of attack on yes i have watched the last
one
yeah and people uh for some reason are
very vocal that like oh it's terrible
now the animation quality is terrible
most of the people don't like the cgi i
think yeah
and yeah if you are used to something
that you which studio have done
this quality yeah and now it's uh we say
actually me too when i see oh this isn't
your job well i'm a bit
i prefer it it was or more on sakura
yeah i i understand yeah but but you can
say
that because you're in there right i
understand that most of some of them
says oh i would prefer sakuga yeah but
it's not a reason to
yeah like the show's ruined
the cgi has ruined my show and it's like
what what do you mean
it's so bizarre but like people are also
complaining about some of the sucker
girl as well
really yeah i've been seeing that like
you know some some i've seen some people
on
twitter have been awesome yeah no but
some people on twitter have you know
like done comparisons with like the
manga panels for example uh
it's completely ruined it's not exactly
the same right like how do you feel
about stuff like that
they push too much yeah because because
i've always wanted because you've worked
on
some pretty high profile shows my jira
had this problem as well
i had this problem a lot do you ever
like when working on it do you ever like
feel the pressure whenever you're
working on a big ip
need to and want to deliver actually um
i know that
most of the when i post something
of my gengar in twitter it's
not my animation they have likes it's
more the the
the ip has likes right i think people
don't i don't know most of the people
like put the like or the retweet oh but
you because it's my
i like this ip yeah no because i like
joe jojo fans are right yeah
jojo i did i did see actually yeah i
think it was my
jojo
because i think i saw the animation that
you did for that yes uh
i love that's like literally like the
best fight in part four like
so good and it was amazing oh man it was
so hard to this day
because it was uh yeah it was in 2018
yeah yeah it was christmas and i spent
all my christmas and new year at working
at the studio i spent
three weeks at sleeping at the studio to
finish before three weeks sleeping at
the studio yeah
yeah just for the pashy fight uh because
i had to finish the hiroakia
layout and after hiraka had my uh wait
so you're working on the hiraka layout
while you're working on the jojo again
yeah i when i finished to hiroca came
back
and and the deadline was of
like the 10th of january and so most of
my co-workers went to was was a tiapiko
so
most of it was in french french people
so they went back to france
i spent the new year and and they came
back and this
when they went to france it was i had
no beer and when they came back i had a
big bear
they just haven't left me off yeah i
haven't left the face
and so i was going to uh
a gold gym to have my shower oh my god
so when you went that must have been
like the case where like if you were
there
all the time you're probably like were
you just thinking about it in the shower
as well you're like thinking about what
you were going to draw
next as well yeah but show it takes time
but
sometimes you you can eat yours may
smell
bad i have to take a shower so optimize
your showers it's just like
do you ever get to the point when you're
just like eating too much time
so i was eating watching an episode
eating and okay if the episode finished
i have finished to eat okay
go back to work you're welcome jojo fans
yeah
and so yes yeah i get sick also
i i think i had him he's a bad one or i
have a
infringer how do you say you're an
influencer yeah i get infringement
[Music]
i was walking like that literally
killing yourself for jojo fans
uh you could say you were
yeah i think you can say i was trying to
do my best on
this one i i think a lot of people would
argue that's one of the best fight
scenes in part five
yeah right like yeah i think it looks
amazing as well yeah i think
all of part five everyone could tell i'm
just saying that because you're here
yeah
it's definitely crowdfunding like i said
uh animations
it's a teamwork yeah so like i said i do
the rough animation after the
the director put some correction so
something that wasn't too little
how can i say oh you can push more this
arm
the director will put it and after the
the
director of animation will put the mod
more
in model right and so these three tabs
are very important after i
receive this correction i redraw it
everything with all the details all the
shadows
all the lights all the perfect frames so
yes it's a teamwork and after this
drawing it will be the
uh in betweener who will clean up and
right
between it's very a teamwork it's not
just
one animator's work is you have the
direct
the director of animations in between
the color
um i'm curious this may be a dumb
question uh
do you like here so when you're drawing
it i assume is the voice acting recorded
at that point or is it not recorded
no it's it's tough way after oh wow
yeah oh wow so you don't even get to
like hear the lines as you're drawing
or anything sometimes you have uh some
um a rough voice
right but it's not the final voices
right
yeah it's mostly it's mostly just like i
think it's written out in the layout
section right of yeah
actually what they're gonna say in this
particular storyboard the storyboard and
after you have the time sheet
when at this moment you have to hu
oh and then the voice actors match that
yeah yeah so all anime is dubbed anime
yeah it is dumb yeah wow
joke mate check made self elitist
i've always been curious because
obviously like you work on a lot of
shonen jump properties
and that's obviously based on like
adapting manga panels
as an animator do you ever do you ever
like look at the manga panels of like
the cut you're animating or do you just
try to go fresh when i do the meetings i
have the manga
on my side because they have print the
manga okay oh your scene will be
on this part of the manga they give it
to me and so
yes yeah it's important to read a bit of
the manga because you to
know how is the characters and
also when you speak with the director he
will say that so this character is more
calm he doesn't have much expression
right and so don't you less
cold man ice face i guess you've got
another personality of the character to
know how they
yes so if you have read the manga it's a
good
good uh good job because uh well the
director will be oh he has read the
manga so he knows the show
and uh right yeah so so all animators
are manga readers
no it depends uh sometimes i didn't
whatever
i read everything
uh the show and so we bet he worked
on it also and i guess then in that
sense i guess like anime originals must
be so hard
yeah so much harder because there's no
yeah there's no yeah there's there's no
reference point
like novels i guess even oh but even
still right like the light i mean light
novels would be even harder because
you've got to you know
if you want a good fact uh when i was
working on dragon ball super brewery
i didn't know it was brewery oh really
what do you think it was
i was working on the dragon ball movie
but i didn't know
who was a bad guy
yeah wait they kept the fact that
probably was a bad guy like is it
from the animators it was no it was a
secret that uh i didn't know
the show was the title of the show is is
barry
oh so you animated that without even
knowing the context of
the entire cut yeah okay oh sick broly
because i have a form because my cuts
was just a
vegeta was a grumbling against goku
yeah oh and so yes and i
i think they were one didn't want some
leaks
uh i mean that makes sense i mean you
know they could also just
sign an nda
what never heard of it i'm curious this
is just such a vague question what is
your like
top anime shows for you personally um
original animation
anything uh i prefer to talk about
original anime
sure because uh well when it's
adaptation you have more the power of
the manga
right and so maybe
i like evangelion like i said yeah and
uh guren lagann
grew up um
yeah the guy next there's just a little
like guy next treat
because they they had the power to do
original animation and
it was great after i don't um
watch much so much shorter than before
so i
maybe i i forgot yeah and also
when you oh what's your top ten you were
yeah you forgot our way no
we were exactly the same on the spot
yeah i do i do want to know that as an
animator are there any like
scenes or any animation cuts that you
really look up to and you
like idolize as legendary and have
inspired you
yeah uh like uh
you have a lot of animation of uh
wow how did he make this movement
right and so yeah when you doing
frame par frame on your animator right
watch the movement okay
oh i just know this this frame is just
exposed at one
two oh this frame is across a tree and
oh at this moment you have the fire come
here and yeah
yeah you analyze the movement like that
frame per frame
every animator is doing like that and
and
so oh so this is the key animation
anime really slow
at first i watched the anime like
everybody yeah yeah and
well what was this movement so i put
stop and fair performance
i guess like an animator or i guess like
director that comes to mind when it
comes to like
amazing animation would be like satoshi
khan right yeah yeah
like
like he managed to like animate in a way
because i think i i saw it in some kind
of interview with him like
way before um that like the reason why
he went into animation
was because his way of directing is too
fast for live action
yeah so whereas like because there's so
many cuts in
con movies where it's just it's like a
blink yeah it's so
fast it's almost subliminal that you
just can't replicate in live action
and it's just i don't know like even i'm
not an animator at all or anything but
like you can watch
a satoshi khan movie and be like how do
you even like think
to animate something like that i have
one of my senpai who had work on a
kon satoshi movie uh it was a the
co-director of
tokyo godfather his name is uh
and uh yeah the
con movies are very realistic realistic
but on the wall
on the character the expression yeah
that uh
you know and said andrew millionaire
actress the way who he makes up
the fiction the reality it's so good
it's like the scene transitions right
now and it's so you can watch it every
time and you have the pressure oh
oh in this category connect with this
yeah
and uh uh and also i like a tokyo
godfather because
i don't know it's a movie you want to
watch it at christmas
yeah it's one of the few christmas anime
movies i feel
like it's not not that it was meant to
be a christmas anime movie
it was just it just happens to be on
christmas right
and yeah but uh when my senpai said
concerto she was one one of the best or
maybe
best anime oh yeah he's really really
fast
yeah execution and he have a perfect
drawing
yeah because i think i i think i saw
that like
satoshi kong used to like draw some of
his own animations
as well yeah because the key animator of
his own he have done mangaka
yes he was manga he had to work on a lot
of
uh a lot of wizards yeah yeah
and so yeah i don't know he have welcome
akira or not i don't remember but uh yes
he was very close with ottoman
with a those a generation of artists
who was at a lot of movie makers in
japan
as an animator what do you think of like
akira for instance like the animation
acura akira is amazing
because i feel that like when when
people say akira they're just like yeah
this animation has an age
like so well even though it's like if
you want to if you want a bit of the
uh for animators a good
animation you have so uh general general
general i've heard that's pretty
legitimate for my senpai he said that
general is the animation realistic the
most push at extreme
right too much extreme that most of the
animators is just
for masturbation of animation
[Laughter]
it's too much but the he said the good
entertainment one and
with the good animation also very pushed
was a memories are the autocad zero oh
yes
and you have the magnetic rows magnetic
fields magnetic fields are so good
each plane of magnetic rows of animation
is a master class
because it's uh most of the frames are
exposition or three three frames in the
less frame but just good drawings good
timings and
masterpieces magnetic rose if you don't
know is like a space opera arc
yeah that's the only way it's going it's
it's it's like how old is that
how old is it it's like from the 90s
like late 90s it was quite uh a while
after but
it's like a magnetic rose is like a
short film that automatically
directed uh i think 40 minutes it's like
a 40 minute like short film
but it's like yeah it's basically just
space opera acura it's the only way to
describe it but it's [ __ ] amazing and
when's this
the same team that uh managed to cross
you have a hachiremeros
ron melrose yeah i didn't watch it but
i had watched some cuts of hashily menos
and
very impressive so yeah
so i guess if you want to like start be
an animator just study those
this is uh the realest one the the the
gold age of animators we say
it's it's interesting hearing an actual
opinion from an actual animator
because you know it's it's because you
know when whenever we think of like oh
what do we think is the best animated
whatever or anime of all time like most
people would say
like redline probably the one that comes
to my mind definitely
do you think that what's your opinion
about like
older animate uh older anime versus like
newer digitized anime oh yeah
um well digital animation yeah
is uh you can get quicker because we can
work at your place and send by mail all
the
the data's it's not paper you don't have
to scan it or
but the problem of the still and
animation industry the most of like i
said the second
animation director most of them are
on paper so because they've been in the
industry for so long yeah so long and
you
they they would like to learn some
digital animation but they
don't have the time of
i learned animation on paper would die
dude
some of my senpai have tried to learn a
digital animation but he was
too much stressed that he have a pain on
stomach and had to go to
hospital oh my god
[Music]
so yes also yeah well so me i'm doing
digital yeah and so i'm doing my layout
in digital so
but if the second have to check it put
correction they have to
uh print it and right so they'll put
correction but
me i'm doing it and then fax it back to
you right yeah yeah so i just had to
scan it
that was a joke right no they saw that's
a joke
i was joking oh god because they they
have
okay the correction is on paper no not
the the
sorry but they have to be princesses to
send
me back by data and to for me to doing
and
digital so yeah so
most of my i think now most of the
ingredients are digital
but uh it depends uh so digital and
paper are a bit uh
but i think in fact the veterans the
good animators are still on paper and
right right nowadays some youngs are
more on digital
but the problem is software you have to
pay it
right and most of the search for
software are expensive yes yeah
commercial licenses are very expensive
and also you you know how much animators
are paid
so they can there is good software like
tv paint
but too expensive yeah right so so uh
yeah also i can't i can't believe the
software is like too expensive
for the people who are going to make the
software so
for the people who are going to use the
software for what it was designed to do
sorry man we want to pay you more but
you know photoshop is like
60 bucks a month you know so it's kind
of expensive yeah
a lot of now young animators are working
on blender
because blender is free yes free and you
can do 3d and 2d animation
at the same time and i think i thought
that was just a meme
so so people in the anime industry are
actually using blender
uh some of them not everybody but uh to
come from somewhere right
so there's so because it's like a meme
now whenever we see something bad that
is like oh this looks like it was
animated in blender
do you think it wasn't any any reality
[ __ ] slowly closes blender
oh yeah in fact the stuff doesn't oh
then
it doesn't the big point uh if you put
it has a
still on like a paper because what's the
correction will be on
paper or on digital but if because
each you if it's on jpeg every soft can
open a jpeg
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm curious being an
animator because like
we do we do anime videos on youtube and
talk about anime and
as someone who watches anime as a job i
cannot like i still enjoy anime but i
can't enjoy anime the same way i used to
as a kid as someone who actually works
on anime
has it changed your view of anime at all
and how you watch it and everything like
that
actually i'm from some of my friends now
they watch less and less animation and
uh going there are more critics right
right right harder but does tend to
happen yeah i can't imagine an animator
casually sitting down to watch an anime
yeah i can't wait for my favorite season
of seven deadly sin
and
[Music]
what did you think about that sorry i
just watched the first season so
okay okay have you oh have you seen
pictures of season three uh i it's in on
twitter yeah
do i need to ask your opinion or is it
obvious
yeah i understand your
i feelings meme it's just it's just like
a disaster like how did it happen
yeah well like i said maybe it's a day
it was a glass that they asked another
studio
maybe they didn't have a second
animation director like i said
if you have a good animation director it
can change
everything interesting it got fixed in
the blue right though right does it i
don't think i think
what we need it must be redone from the
ground yeah yeah yeah yeah
like at what point do you just be like
all right just don't air it don't add it
just redo it like just
start over please okay sorry what were
we saying
sorry oh critics of the critics uh
yeah but when now uh when i watch anime
i
look more about the technique how they
made up and to
wow how did he do that like i do a frame
bar frame
but also when you watch too much
animation now you know the pattern okay
the guy
wants another secret if you launch a 2-3
second you
[Music]
yeah i guess for animators it's just
like watching anime is just like
study material isn't it yeah for for
most of us animators
uh now one of my senpai he said i don't
watch anime now i'm not
more watching live movies and if i watch
anime i'm
watching uh animation of honda of or in
osan
oh i think it's maybe the the best
animators in japan
right uh kind of to see where the
benchmark yeah
well i think um you know some nickname
is the machine
the machine what has inoy sun worked on
uh most of the directors of uh
manity crows are uh basically like
like you know the like the vip of that
oh yeah
or he's uh you have a gengashu gingka
do you know what is gingka shoe uh
gengar so the key poses a sure
of a uh archive archive it's it's like
an archive
collection yes it's on a book our book
of key frames
and a lot of if when it's in osan
every animator's because it's you know
he's uh
he's the man of it yeah yeah wow it's so
cool
yeah so you have some animators
who are very very talented and they are
like a sushi or sound of trigger uh
nakamura yatakov bones
those names are very uh they have
put their touch in animation industry
that now
it's like the kind of animators where
like even if you're not exactly like a
sakura guitar you can just be like
that's a sushio yeah yeah yeah nowadays
whatever uh
nakamura it's a very famous in young
animator so you could
like using a lot of uh
impact frames yeah um i did notice that
there's a lot of more impact frames like
impact frames is you know in the fight
scene
where it has like the kind of negative
of the image whereas like
you have you have the fight animation
and then sometimes it will just like
go into like the black and white
negative of it oh yeah like a few frames
that's
i'm pretty sure he started that trend
right yeah he said i think he was one
the first and you know he's very famous
because of his
yuta pong and it's a day brexit with the
cube form
yeah so you've you've definitely seen
some of his fights he did a lot of
a lot of like the my hero academia
fights every shot
you say on my academy holy [ __ ] it's him
yeah okay yeah
like when the ground explodes then it's
like blocks of yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah that's cool yeah
whenever it explodes it's like square
blocks and
yeah he's now very famous of because he
puts his touch and so
most of every young animators he
imitate him learn from his animation
that's great
yeah i guess like you know you probably
plan to do like more stuff right but
like
i guess like what's like one anime that
you've looked at or like one creator
that you looked at and being like
i wish i worked on that is that like an
anime where you just like
the animation like all the story was
just like so cool and you think like
man i wish i had like worked on that um
i don't know if there's in fact
it's difficult to put just one right but
um
for example i would like if i had the
occasion i would like to work
but now it's finished but the last
evangelion film i would like to
in fact there is a it depends on some of
my schedule
if it's possible if i if i have the
level or not
because i if for evangelion things are
only just
very very very few animate i'm using
very
very the most strongest animators in
japan because it's evangelion
so
does it hurt when you have to deny like
a job that you really wanted to do
because of yourself yes yes
i have so much denied some proposal some
good stuff
still don't announce
yeah i also have a girlfriend but so if
you have to yeah like i said
it's a good balance you have to find
your privacy
your work doing some uh two months ago
because some some animators
have walked too much and there was
married divorce because
so yeah and they sent me don't mess like
me
i'm sorry i'm sorry honey i'm married to
my hero academia thank you very much
is there any ips you still want to work
on that you haven't oh yeah
quite a lot of i would like to actually
in my
uh part six of jojo is my prefer i like
julian
oh yeah of course and let's go uh
i would like to work on ginseng also
right uh and like i said i like you
pretty much jump
so but uh stuff around yeah stuff i like
but one of those fans but uh
the reminder is not also the
big ip also it's a walk also with good
senpai
right yeah actually i'm working on the
movie
and i've learned so much and
it's not an it's it's a
amazing it's an amazing amazing
experience for work
yeah yeah you can learn every day that's
cool
or something man i can i don't
understand this way and
i'll show you show you and uh cool yeah
it's
it's so much cool it sounds like you're
like every animator is constantly just
learning and training themselves of
course we want
we want to push our limits and
uh but sometimes uh you you have
a war and you you have to pass it but
you i power how can i sounds like a
shown an anime in itself
one of the offices blasting the you say
right
every animator is in their training yeah
yeah you've got to push past your limits
this is a bit like at that time carpal
tunnel nonsense push
so that's why sometimes i saw you
listening some music
or uh yeah or listening some podcasts of
your guys
yeah oh wow well you have you have your
own podcast don't you
uh yes um was the mistakes
uh anime was a mistake
sorry french people
our experience of the animation industry
how the good the bad
and how to don't redo our mistakes
right and um yes and sorry it's in
french
so any of the french trash taste viewers
you can go and listen to that
there is quite also a english podcast of
animation
like a dust studio uh union by stbm
of uh on tonally animation all the
all other in english and
i think for people who cannot understand
english for french people which was good
to do
yeah yeah exactly and you have a twitter
right and twitter instagram also all
right and that'll be all on screen right
now and links in the description
please go and follow ken yeah yes and uh
please please please what are you doing
already
come on look at look at what he's done
he just
you know who else deserves the clout our
patrons look at these
lovely patrons shout out to those guys
if you like to support the show then
make sure to go over to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on follow us
on twitter as well yes and the subreddit
and if you wanna
listen we've just hit 100k on our
subreddit did we mention that last time
i don't know i don't think i don't think
we did yeah so thanks to all the people
on the reddit and uh also
make sure to listen to us on spotify if
you don't want to see our faces and uh
trash these episodes will have subtitles
or captions so if you do want to listen
to them they'll have them
just click on the cc button if you're
interested probably said that at the
start of the year yeah right not the end
but from now on you know yeah now you
know yeah and uh
thank you very much for coming on again
thank you missed
most education probably the most
educational episode we've had
um it feels nice just not to not have
three buffoons arguing
we're like yeah i think this is what
happens in the anime
it's nice
i'm happy to if i could
i don't know if it's teaching you but a
lot of you know
yeah i have some information about the
backstage uh yeah yeah yeah
one episode it's a lot of work a lot of
people who work on it and
sleepless nights and over works but
for quality and doing everybody are
doing the best i mean the work speaks
for itself right
give love to the animators that's the
bottom line basically
and anyway that's been this episode of
trash taste hope you guys enjoyed it and
we
will see you next time
i was like stumbling there
you